هذه اول شاحنه ستدخل من مناطق شمال لشرق
سوريا اي من مناطق الاداره الذاتيه الى
مناطق المعارضه شمال غرب البلاد عبر معبر
ام جلود عبر البوابه الرئيسيه التي يتم
فتحها الان امام اولى الشاحنات التي سوف
تدخل الى مناطق المعارضه هذه المنطقه هي
منطقه منبج وبالتالي هذه هي الشاحنه
الاولى التي ستدخل من مناطق الاداره
الذاتيه الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا هذه
الشاحنه تحمل مواد اغاثيه خيام وايضا
مستلزمات طبيه لاطباء بلا حدوث ستقدم عبر
يعني احد
المنظمات التي تعمل مع
ما اطباء بلا حدود هناك عدد كبير من
الشاحنات يفترض انها ستدخل الى مناطق شمال
الغرب سوريا حوالي 30 شاحنه محمله بالوقود
مقدمه من الاداره الذاتيه اضافه الى حوالي
72 الشاحنه مقدمه من المبادرات الفرديه
والجماعيه ووجهاء العشائر ايضا هناك خمسين
شاحنه من المساعدات
الانسانيه والاغاثيه مقدمه من منظمات
المجتمع المدني في حال لو تم سماحه بشكل
نهائي لهذه الشاحنه بالدخول واستلامها من
طرف المعارضه حيث اقف الان في طرف
المعارضه السوريه في بوابه معبر ام جلود
ستتبعها شاحنات اخرى للمنظمات وايضا
للمبادرات الفرديه
والجماعيه اذا هذه كانت الشاحنه الاولى
التي تدخل من شمال سوريا الى مناطق
المعارضه السوريه التي تحكم شمال غرب
البلاد كاولى الشاحنات التي ينتظرها
العشرات من الشاحنات الاخرى المحمله
بالمواد الاغاثيه والانسانيه والتي من
المترقب ان تدخل الى هذه المناطق اعتبارا
من اليوم